[Music]
you sent this to me
um
and you said all of it is good now
i've gone through the comments of this
video merch and um
i oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i was i was
psyched when i saw this last night sammy
you may know this gentleman sammy i
watched i watched some of this last
night and i had to set it to royce
immediately somebody even told me you
could even start at the beginning
because other people were saying you
could even start the everything about
this
is the whole thing this whole thing is a
goddamn train wreck okay so
sammy the bull is recently got out of
prison and he started a podcast like
everybody else um and he went on the
fighter and the kid look how tight his
jeans are today he went on the fighter
and the kid to promote
um i think jamie the bull when he met
these guys he's like yeah he's praying
guy you're all right but what's with the
fanuc over here
what's with this fanuc wearing uh capri
pants all right let's okay he's [ __ ]
in his his rolled up jeans and his
sperry's let's see
you know i did time i did 22 years in
prisons and i was with so many guys
especially black guys
whoa wait a minute i'm sorry
phrasing sir
okay wow we're already two seconds in
and brendan's not saying the stupidest
thing yet give hey give him a break he's
nice
his windows his brain runs on window on
internet explorer it takes a little bit
for him can i
repeat what he just said sure go ahead
man the people could maybe hear what was
wrong with that
i was in prison for 22 years
i was with a lot of guys
especially black guys
he has a type that's why they call
sounds like you're having sex with dudes
why do they why do you think they call
him sammy the bull
[Laughter]
ah yeah that's right because they call
me simmer the bull cause i'm always
prepping the ball
around and said sam what do you think on
this case i think you're dead
why
because you got some broken down [ __ ]
lawyer yeah
and uh your prosecutor is an ex-cop an
ex-drunk have you tried being a snitch
like me
yeah we see what you got to do is
is have a boss
that the government hates so much
that they forgive you for all your
murders okay brendan's like okay i know
joe rogan the government does hate him
this is actually going to work out for
me
[Laughter]
and they have a team of magnificent
lawyers
they have the fbi as their investigators
and they have a 98 percent
conviction rate because they make the
laws yeah so that's what you're up most
people think they're smarter than that
most people say we must your dad works
for the cia brian why don't we relax
people think they're smarter than the
fbi but the fbi's got some smart unless
you organize it
yeah right it's not the fbi because yeah
all the people in fbi are gonna crime
used to be an organized crime and they
got deals now they work for the fbi it's
not that they're smarter is that they're
hiring the people that are doing it
yeah and they brought their training
manuals from their old company exactly i
mean obviously you know why do you think
these places have ndas so you can't
bring all your knowledge once you leave
a place
they got well and they the laws i mean
they have bugs yeah they're people
confidential informants they got
everything going from for them so you're
going into a fight you know i'm looking
at these guys in this room over here all
these big [ __ ] that i mean i'm
gonna fight them the both of them i i
i've got to be on my mind if i think i'm
going to win i'm going to fight but find
the game
[Laughter]
i got to give you that intro for people
who don't know because for me people
don't understand okay here's what i'm
going to do now that youtube and i love
this i don't ever say i love things you
know the most viewed parts but you want
you want to do that let's skip to most
feud ready
all right here we go
dog there i think he's a
minus 105. it's a great freaking uh pick
but all three have to win and then all
you gotta do just head to the app right
now under the ufc page check out my
picks bet on it and ride along with your
thick friend here right now all
customers can place the same game parlay
for saturday's fight if it hits you
double your winnings question when we do
live reads
do you see us just reading it off of a
do you see what you see you see him
and then
you the parlay picks are the picks and
turn over for more info
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code fighter new customer
can bet five dollars on any ufc 276
fighter them to win san diego
[Laughter]
get 100 in free bets no matter what
that's code fighter this saturday at
draftking sportsbook wait why is this
the most oh oh he's about okay let's see
official sports brand partner the ufc
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply seashell notes for details
did he do it again he said see show
notes for details he did it again
don't read that part
he is really dumb yeah
my question
is
how did you speak to yourself how do you
[ __ ] stay safe toughness yeah get
through that how did you not go crazy
oh no no uh brandon he's he's asking you
dude but the way he is like royce
pretend like you're asking sammy the
bullet question like like how i would
ask him a question yeah like the same
thing brian just asked him about like
his you know how did you stay sane yeah
how did hey man being in prison must be
really tough like i'm really tough in
jail
anyway prison was really tough and
really hard in prison
prison was re must be a really hard
sammy how did you deal hard-pressed with
it how do you make the brain work
you know what brendan you know what
brennan but he does that all the time
he's always talking over brian gallon
well i one of the comments that i read
was oh this interview's great sammy the
bull is awesome i'd love to know more
but brennan kept interrupting him every
time he spoke you really did
yourself in three minutes yeah i was
asked this question a lot of times but
i'm gonna answer it that
we all
have no idea
how much
i have no idea
having us
if something that we can't control like
a plane crashes and we're stuck on a
[ __ ] island yeah we have you have no
idea how much you could withdraw from
your body to survive and to do certain
things and you know but being in the
hole like that
i mean it was the worst time of my life
six and a half years i
hit you double your winnings daddy
download the draftking sports book app i
listen to your podcast and you're
talking about one time you and john
gotti went to this restaurant or bars
and there's girls there and john sends
you over to pick up the girls they're
pretty girls you go over to them but
their dads are somewhere in another
crime families they're like you can't do
this hey brandon you know how this would
work
let me tell you as someone who's like
i'm not a professional interviewer in
any way but i've done enough of these
if he said something on his podcast
here's how i would say it
okay
you're this is how mercer sam here's
where we go
hey um you mentioned on your podcast a
fun a funny story about gotti at a
restaurant with some girls what was that
you want to tell us
let the guy that lived it
tell you the story you're repeating so
he's doing the [ __ ] remember chris
farley snl thing that that was awesome
you you
remember when you
would work for john gotti
jesus that was awesome what a dummy
john and it's like i i mean obviously
you guys weren't short on girls i
believe
i'll be i'll be i believe you guys is
your girl
let him
tell the story this is how you do it hey
brandon can you buy a vowel you know you
were telling us an interesting story off
the air about you and john gotti and the
two girls one night you tried to pick up
tell me can you talk about that on the
air
and then let him tell the story he was
there
not you brendan
and people that liked you because so
much power i bet it was so fun man
besides they were killing them
i bet it was so fun besides like killing
the stuff i bet it was so much fun you
know being in the mafia is fun he's got
a child like understanding of everything
he thinks the mafia is just casino right
you know what i mean like that's his
only point of reference just booze and
broads and gambling all day what about
the ricoh charges yeah
there's definitely times that that it's
fun that's why the people love the mafia
people
legitimate guys there's guys who are
tough guys who are not killing people
not in the mafia they're tough guys and
they love that because it's scorsese
because of scorsese this is because of
scorsese it's because of scorsese and
and
coppola
not so much as daughter
they almost that's almost in them
themselves yeah could be a new a little
bit him or a guy ham it could be in
anybody really i don't know
no no well well i don't know
all right whatever yeah
oh wow
he doesn't want to
he doesn't want to banter with brendan
and he's annoyed with him
okay whatever can you imagine
my man i think it's in everybody
everybody and everybody yeah and that's
what makes that's brian just trying to
get back on track that's for brian i
think it's you know look i'm not even
really interesting or funny but i mean
i'm all you got for the show so
the mafia
this thing back
lovable to people they kill themselves
so they don't care about that part but
their life
the the running around the broads the
cars the drinking the gambling the
joking sitting in the car
everybody's got suits
you dressing like a dime piece papa
that little bit of taste looking around
dollar bills
pop by nice calves
of
you know breaking the rule [ __ ] the
government you know you
after a while you're born
getting [ __ ] by the government
constantly constantly so more or less
you know i am no fan of the government
okay
obviously
you were running a mafia i mean
like i get it i'm we're not talking
about speed cameras where we're gonna be
like ah these [ __ ] guys trying to
take more money of us you're doing
organized crime and killing people let's
not [ __ ] you know what i mean like
come on
you can't threaten people with violence
now right yeah well brian that's all you
[ __ ] do that's literally
all you do brian that's your entire
personality
and then brendan's gonna be like hey you
do you have any experience fighting the
asian mafia
the yakuza the triads and stuff because
i need some help with the situation
[ __ ] yakuza i've got this these mafia
guys on reddit
[Laughter]
well i mean you can but peyton yeah show
them to 38.
uh-oh
shitty baby she's your hater she's the
one who cares don't think she's the one
who carries the guy she's the one
i [ __ ] knew it i knew it because she
was so
quiet oh you guys are showing the dirty
work tell her to do an office pop with
it
it'd be funny she took her wig off i'm
like this is not a [ __ ] that's just a
hard looking you gotta see that move
man it's all a jumbled mess huh
they're having fun okay hold on let's
see how much fun brenton's about to talk
it's gonna be fun we should not even
once a month we can do it once a week
we're sitting down we're playing cards
we're joking how many clowns tune into
that we're just we're just being like we
were in the past talking about broads
talking about drinking oh man i love
what you guys talk about girls come in
bro child you're right girls bro girls
mafia is fun he doesn't want to hear
about like you know how did they [ __ ]
trick the government and what did they
do and you know how did they work with
people there is very super interesting
stuff about the mafia right if you
really look into it i think we all agree
right i'm sure you've read a bunch about
them off he's like really
interesting [ __ ] how they infiltrate it
all that stuff
all brandon cares about is like were the
girls hot
what was the [ __ ] like
how did you get [ __ ] if f1 if f150
didn't make a raptor until 2007.
how did you get [ __ ] did you guys do
that what did you do when when you
parked outside of the mafia club did you
park out front with your sports car like
i do at comedy clubs
did you also ever get your dick sucked
by bobby lee's girlfriend yeah yeah i
did yeah no i did actually i did trash
tuesday last week yeah that broad she's
a [ __ ] coos
[Laughter]
and then brendan's like cb i told you b
b c i b i told you
listen you know our friend mike stymie
was running a phone company he goes to
see
this captain's
girlfriend
she has this company so he's putting a
pitch on and he puts the pitch onto her
and everything he comes back and he
talks to us
unbeknownst to us we're caught on tape
so he shows a picture
and i
said
she's got a gorgeous [ __ ] ass bro
this guy does a
this guy's throwing a podcast i mean i'm
already bored by sammy the bull yeah
sami the bull sucks um listen sammy the
bull trust me i've seen the fbi records
i know you talk but nobody really wants
to hear it anymore okay
i mean unless there's like rolling
stones music playing behind it and you
have rayleigh in it i really don't care
dude sammy the bull is the most
egregious example of like
how evil the government is when it cuts
deal deals with of course
because i mean he was a prolific
murderer he murdered many people
many many many many people yep and now
you've done a podcast and they cut a
deal just because john gotti got off on
two trials
and they were [ __ ] sick of them and
he took it personal
obviously i know what happened i watched
the john travolta movie gotti i think i
know what happened okay to john yeah an
abomination yeah
but they found the head of the triad he
was a guy you know he was on reddit
coming after us the leader of the
chinese triads or whatever the mafia guy
they say
oh god at first i wasn't looking up i
honestly thought that was brendan for a
second
i swear to god
was sell he would do a food cart he
would he would make food he was in
chinatown he sounds like a terrible
guest yeah
listen i know
johnny khan was was
one of the bosses in the chinese
mafia johnny khan
and uh i was in prison with him when you
go over the bridge into chinatown you
ever see that big big tower
that was his building oh wow i did time
with him he hated john by the way in
prison hated him with a [ __ ] passion
yeah well so did you apparently
you know you killed a bunch of people
for him you killed more people than john
gotti did
yeah no honestly that is verifiably true
yeah that's a legitimate fact oh [ __ ]
christ
i i everybody's getting a podcast now i
mean seriously we're gonna give brendan
chaba podcast